i'd rather die than compromise my gut
hmm yeah it just doesn't feel good
enough like
if you're gonna lose lose on your own
sword
the garyvee audio experience
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk uh
super excited for this
episode uh as many of you know i've
become
shockingly selective during covet and
even right before it
on guests on the podcast i've i you know
just
just want to be thoughtful about what
builds these pipes and
you know uh to me i want to be selective
on
individuals who i think could bring
value uh
in their stories or their execution and
today is one of such
things i'm super super excited to have
jamie on the show
um i'm gonna let her introduce herself
and then i've got a series of questions
because i've been watching from afar
as she's developed her career and
executions and uh
and i'm excited to uh share them with
this audience i'm sure many of you will
know but i know many many
of you won't i just that's how it always
works i
jimmy every time i'm on a podcast like
everybody knows i'm like and then on
twitter
and first time i think people you know
there's so much out in the world but
i know you also have a new book so
that's gonna be fun to talk about so
without further ado uh why don't you
tell the vayner nation who you are uh
and what's cooking and i know that we'll
probably post this in a couple days
which is right before the february 23rd
date
which is exciting and so why don't you
give us the 4-1-1
all right well gary thank you so much
for having me um i'm super excited to
share this big week with you too and
your whole community so thank you
yeah my name is jamie kern lima and uh
i'm probably
most well known uh like if you google my
story you'll probably see denny's
waitress
builds billion dollar company so i
started the company my living room
called it cosmetics and
went through three years of hearing no
from just about everyone
in the world got down to my last
thousand dollars and um
kept going eventually built that company
and sold it to l'oreal for over a
billion
dollars and uh and you know but that's
what you see online and why i wrote my
first ever book believe it is because
the real story behind the story is you
know i'm a girl who went from not
believing in myself
uh to learning how to believe in myself
and like doubting i'm enough to having
to to learn to know i'm enough and
just trying to figure out how to get
through all the setbacks and
and kind of step into the person i was
born to be so i know that's not just my
story it's a stormy
story of so many people listening right
now
um on their own journeys of learning to
believe in themselves and
and trust themselves and and know
they're enough and i just want to say
thank you to you gary also for all that
you do to inspire everyone
on their own journeys you know you kind
of always share the story behind the
story of everything so that's why i'm
super super honored to be part of your
show thank you for saying that let's
let's take a step back because it is
such an
such a massive accomplishment it's like
so fun to be on here and i think
you know i've just i've been trying to
be more thoughtful about giving more
examples of people who've made it than
you know
i think we get into the laziness of and
they're incredible elon musk or bezos or
oprah
or you know but i feel like there are
some really crazy ass
stories out there and yours is one of
them so
if you don't mind to indulge me because
i'm going to enjoy it
i think it really matters i think you
know for i get hit up all the time by
immigrants like
kids that grow up that are not good
students and immigrant families
when they see me it means something i
think your story is so
universal with so few and i mean so few
to get to the sheer level of financial
success
um and and i think even the way you set
this up around emotional success and
things that nature more people can get
there and don't need the financial
levels that you've achieved but but i do
think knowing that this is an
entrepreneurial audience i i do think
it's important to get into a little bit
of the details because i think you might
say one sentence that might inspire
somebody to persevere
because you know you went with the macro
down to a thousand bucks like there's
some real stuff there like
break this down like give me five
minutes of how you came up with the
company idea
yeah and then like and then like 12 or
13 highlights of
the of the path of how it went down yeah
sure
so you know i it's so funny because i
was working as a journalist which i
thought was my dream job and ever since
i was a little girl i would watch oprah
every single day gary and i i thought oh
my gosh i want to spend my life telling
other people's stories like i knew that
was what i was going to do my whole life
and so
i was i was what i thought was working
in my dream job as
a news anchor and then i got a skin
condition uh called rosacea
and i learned there's no cure for it and
i would be
anchoring the news live and what would
start to happen is my my cheeks
uh would get so bright red and inflamed
that they
the makeup would start to break up and
this redness would come through and so
i went through this season in my life
that i thought was a setback
like a big setback i would be anchoring
the news live and i'd hear from my
producer
uh in my ear piece who's just trying to
have my back they'd be like there's
something on your face there's something
on your face
you can wipe it off you need to wipe it
off and i knew there was nothing i could
wipe
off um and so i went through this sort
of like struggle with
um confidence with more inner critic
stuff thinking am i going to get fired
am i going to lose ratings
but in that set and that season the
setback like i didn't realize it was
actually
well so many times our setbacks are
really our setups right
for something that that we're supposed
to actually
do and i started just trying to find
any makeup product that would work and i
realized nothing
would and i realized that when you see
ads on tv
you typically just see models with
perfect skin or they're photoshopped and
so what what year what year is this to
set it up for everybody
yeah so this is 2007 because when this
started happening yeah
and and i kind of thought okay i'm in my
dream job
but i started getting this gut feeling
like
what if i could figure out how to make a
product that worked for me
it'd probably help a whole lot of other
people too
but i sat there in this weird spot and
maybe a lot of people are in the spot
now where
i lost some people are at this weird
spot
yep go ahead you want to take right back
okay guys
we i love like i'm not one of these post
product you know back to
yeah you know i think it's crazy when
people like start from the beginning or
like
like the audience listening like i i
don't know for everybody who's listening
at home right now but i have a funny
feeling that zoom and stream yard
and google hangouts or facetime has
frozen for everybody many times over the
last year so
we will put some we'll put some we'll
put some funny music over that keep
going we kind of watched you at the
point where you're like
i found myself in this funny spot yeah
i thought you know i was in the season
the setback and and really it was a
setup so
i was in this spot though where my gut
was telling me like you need to
you need to do this you need to go after
it but my head was saying
you're not qualified uh you have almost
no money you have no connections like
you know
i knew nothing gary about how do i start
a beauty company like i had no idea
um but you know when i look back at
everything i just want to share this
with you and your whole audience because
i i think we're in this
culture a lot of times where it's like
don't quit whatever you do just don't
quit don't quit don't quit
and i think the victory isn't when you
don't quit i think the victory is when
you're able to tune in and hear your own
gut
and know like sometimes knowing
when to let go of a dream is as
important as knowing when to go after
one
and in that moment i thought it was in
my dream job i thought my whole life i
this is what i want to do is share other
people's stories and all of a sudden i
just had this
gut feeling like i'm supposed to quit
what i thought was my dream job and
start this crazy
entrepreneurial journey that didn't make
sense in my head it just made sense in
my gut and
when i look back over so many of these
moments i feel like
listening to my gut is like like those
are the moments that change our lives
do you think intuition is grossly
misunderstood
and underrated i think it's
misunderstood because i think that we
have
so much noise around us i believe gary
like every person listening whether
they're 12 years old or
112 years old i think i think we all
have
intuition like a knowing inside of us
then i think our knowing is
always right i think our knowing is
i'm sorry finish no no i was gonna say i
think our knowing is more powerful
even than anyone else's advice but i
think
that we have so much noise around us
from other people's opinions to our own
self-doubt
right that it gets so loud we start to
not even be able to hear
our own intuition anymore so most people
haven't even heard their own intuition
in a long time or they don't know how i
would tell you that i couldn't applaud
that pov more
it is my belief that my happiness which
matters to me the most and then comma
my success which i have pride in my
professional life
is 100 predicated on my inability
to compromise my intuition i believe
intuition
is uncomfortably misunderstood
i believe that a students
and very narrow uh kind of
rigid thinkers which most people are
have demonized
intuition i think intuition is looked
upon as careless
and is positioned as silly or flaky
or whatever else you want to call it and
i will tell you that
it is basically something that i've
started exploring with myself
and i believe it is a category of
information that i will talk a lot more
about
because basically everything good that
i've decided
that has gone on to be very very good
has been far more based on intuition
than anything else
i you know i have the exact same
experiences
like like how i broke through this crazy
crowded beauty
space and and built something that
ended up passing all of the the
companies i used to save my tip money as
a denny's waitress to buy in department
stores
was literally figuring out how to hear
my own intuition and then trust it
that's the other part of it right and
like i love that you're talking about
this and by the way
for so many people that's how they hear
god or their faith whatever faith they
practice right
or or even the universe they hear it
through their own intuition and
um i think it's like i think it's your
superpower that's what i think
um i think that it's literally the one
thing that changes everything
that if i were an entrepreneur or even
just someone that wanted to go after a
dream or
i mean that's the biggest thing i would
focus on is how do i tune into and hear
my own gut and how do i
differentiate that from all the ways
around your other people
what what is your intuition funny
uh i do say that a lot i just realized
what is your intuition
on the other ingredient needed for this
to actually work
which is the ability to be comfortable
with failure
because i'll tell you the reason i'm in
love with my intuition
is a couple of reasons one humility my
intuition has been
the driver of so much success it has
also led to many failures
it is my capacity to be comfortable in
my micro failure
that has allowed me to continuously
trust my intuition
thoughts yeah thoughts are okay
i'm going to say something you might
freak out over or just really excited
i think i think every time your
intuition leads you to a failure
i don't think it's a failure i think
it's part of your your
your uh destiny and your destiny and
your serendipitous
journey where you had to build that
muscle
so can i stop you because i don't think
that's crazy at all i actually it makes
me want to ask you something else
do you believe that your optimism
in your blood and soul is also a
required ingredient to make what we're
talking about here work
because what i'm thinking about is the
people on the other side right
and now we're listening to two
successful people talking about
intuition and they're basically saying
[ __ ] these two
like okay good but like you guys got
lucky and i know
that i know a million people that have
quote unquote got lucky in different
levels of success
financially um but have happiness of
their journey
but it is ingredients it's a it's a
concoction it is not a straight like
it's kind of like diseases right it's
never like oh pepper no
it's like for example with cove that i
hear like it's this thing and then the
zinc can get in
it's mixtures right hiv right it was a
cocktail
i'm listening carefully to you we went
intuition
now what i want to know we then we went
with capacity to be comfortable with
failure aka
humility now i'm asking you because your
answer is like no no gary
let me send you a different way and i'm
with you on this
i do them as micro failures but to your
point life is so serendipitous you just
don't know
you know but i but i'm fascinated by
your next
the next statement which looks like this
do you believe that your optimism
allows this all to work because if you
are looking at losses
as in well this was meant to be part of
my journey and this scar
is actually attractive because that's
how i think about it i think about
all those losses as scars and like that
scar giving you character and that's
attractive
do you believe that optimism was an
incredibly big factor
and ingredient in your success i think
optimism is great i think though that
knowing why we're doing what we're doing
listening to our gut
and going after our calling like
literally living our calling
i think that's the victory hold on hold
on though yeah here's an interesting
question
every human needs levels of affirmation
along the way to sustain that
right and so in the beginning where
you're not seeing those results
for many and you might have you know
i've always seen results pretty quickly
in my good calls so i i always try to
think about
someone who's not seeing it so because
they don't have optimism they have
delusion and they think they're going to
be
you know beyonce when they can't sing
right
do you feel like the you know believing
in your calling
gets affirmed along the way what do you
rely on in that beginning
don't you think blind faith is actually
completely grounded in optimism
i mean for me my faith is a huge part of
my
life i'm going to take religion as faith
out
i'm saying i'm i was you know i'm just
thinking about you
young you in this moment and i'm really
fascinated by it
i'm meant to do this because what you're
talking about is what i love which is
the journey
yep yeah i don't i'm trying to get into
your
go ahead please yeah yeah i was gonna
say i don't think the victory is the
outcome right i don't think the victory
listen i know i know how accomplished
you are and everything
i know you're gonna have the new york
jets one day i know all that
but i don't think that's the victory i
think the victory is
is is the journey of actually like
stepping into all of who you are
and not talking yourself out of your own
truth and what i mean by that is this
journey of that we're talking about
right
of course optimism of course uh
resiliency to get back up
every time you're knocked down of course
all those things but i think that so
many people listening right now
if they don't ever learn to get still
and hear their own truth and hear their
own intuition
i think what's going to happen and this
is what happens to most people is they
end up staying in their comfort zone
they end up
putting their own immediate failures on
a pedestal or other people's opinions
are self-doubt
they end up talking themselves out of
their own truth and then they end up
never actually becoming the person
they're born to be
so for me i don't think like the fact
that i was able to build a billion
dollar company is the victory
i think the moments of me knowing
this is what i'm supposed to do and
trusting it even when it doesn't make
sense
um and i'll give you one example okay of
of this so
and maybe this will this will make sense
because optimism of course is important
and i know what you're saying
but i think the biggest thing is
learning how to hear yourself and trust
yourself
i really believe that um there is a
moment
how do you define that that as a term
because i view that as
self-belief and confidence and optimism
i'm just i think that you're such a you
know very quickly i'm like oh she's
okay this is this is my sister like
literally within the first three seconds
oh i see oh i see so i just what do you
i'm hoping a different voice might do
this for the listener i'm trying to
figure out
what words you use to quantify i fully
agree with you
everything you're saying i i'm wondering
if you view optimism
as so i think optimism similar to what
we were talking about earlier
sometimes gets pegged as delusion hmm
yeah
and i think you see where i'm going
because i could almost feel you doing
that right now and i'm like i get you
sister
because like like this isn't why i like
it's so great
word smithing matters right like for
example hustle
has gotten demonized as like burnout so
i no longer use it
because i don't need it you know what
i'm going to call it work ethic call it
what you want
here's what i can tell you for all the
belief you had and all the love you had
in doing what you were doing i'm pretty
confident based on your outcome
that there was a lot of work ethic there
and so whatever you want to
call it and sometimes i just think about
i know the word hustle triggers people
so i use the word work ethic now because
i don't want to
ever not let anybody who cares to listen
to me not realize
that if you don't put in the work it is
impossible
thoughts on that yeah i agree with that
and i just had a big aha moment that
what you're saying is optimism
i a billion percent agree with and i i
i'm thinking of that right now as belief
um same thing yep and now i'm right
there with you
like here's the thing when and then i
want to share one quick story with you
too that
hopefully someone listening right now
maybe needs to hear but
i mean when i look back it's like when
people are like oh how did you start
with close to nothing and build a
billion dollar company it's like
yeah i got you know i got back up every
time i got knocked down and i
followed my gut and i worked really
really hard uh but i do think that one
of the most important things i did was
just
like how to build a billion dollar
company from nothing like i think one of
the most important things is making that
decision to believe that you can
yes and for me that that's optimism
exactly what you're saying and i guess i
call it belief so yeah a million percent
with that um
and one more thing just on maybe people
listening to us right now they're like
oh
gary like jamie i you know
i trust my gut sometimes and it's wrong
or i tried it once and it didn't work or
i don't know how you know don't know how
to hear my own intuition
i just want to say i think that it is a
muscle that we can all
build and i think people have to give
themselves grace right it's almost it
reminds me of like when you start to
meditate
a lot of people try it and they can't do
it they're like they go through their
to-do list in their head the whole time
they're trying to metadata but you have
to like give yourself grace and start
and
you know what i would say whether it's
entrepreneurs or
someone who's 14 years old and out there
dating right now i would say
when you start to look back at your
experiences
and think about moments when you had a
gut feeling
and you didn't follow it like we've all
dated like a sketchy guy or
had and like you're like you know his
phone didn't really just just
like shut off for three days or he
didn't lose the phone
like you know and then you kind of make
that decision of like
okay talk to me about i mean we are
really vibing here i actually want to
talk to you offline because i just have
had
the thought um talk to like i'm starting
to wrap but i'm so excited
insecurity yeah right because you're
like to me like
thinking to my girlfriends friends that
were girls that were dating guys
that i knew what the guys were doing
which was they were preying
on my friends insecurities and sometimes
brilliant beautiful girls and i'm like
this
[ __ ] sucks yeah this woman he really
triggered something in me this woman i'm
thinking about four or five friends
through the last 20 years
this woman is subjectively and if we had
100 people ask
is a million miles better than this man
this man has figured out the cheat code
that if he makes her feel insecure he
has the leverage
thoughts yep i think that happens every
single day
and i think that we uh
we look for people that um
treat us how we believe we deserve to be
treated like like we
find partners so you go you go with
cool before you worry about jerk off
johnny
this is a big game of your own
lack of self love towards you it's your
own lack of self love because here's the
thing
and i don't know your friends i'll just
say this i'll make a general statement
you appreciate this this was mainly 17
to 25 years old because you see that so
commonly there i mean
in later stages you know people are in
really deep relationships and you're in
different parts of your life when you're
going through high school and college
you're spending so much time with people
you get better reads to the clean
the cleanness of the data is like oh
this is really [ __ ] up
when you're older you're running in
different circles you don't really get
to see it as easily
right and i think that whether you know
no matter your age
this is what i believe i think that
when someone's treating us like crap and
we stay with them
i think it's because it's we deep down
inside don't believe we deserve better
yet
and here's the thing for for people like
that that are dating your friend
who's totally screwing them over right
if you were to bring the
the best most most amazing beautifully
like kind person into their space
that same girl would probably put them
in the friend zone
a quick house yeah because they don't
get a clue down inside
yeah and and also
people value different things through
their life
you know one of the things you know
right now we live through a generation
desperately interested in blaming social
media for lack of accountability
they're just pointing fingers right like
if you are in a good place with yourself
and your perspective is strong around
gratitude
an anonymous person's negative comment
is not going to ruin your day
yeah and i think when it does i think
that's what's so tough right that's when
it's a reminder to ourselves like oh
yeah we have some more work to do
and one of the things i talk about in my
book believe it is just
that ability to learn to turn down the
volume
uh on certain things and turn up the
volume on other things like
one one example and we were three years
into building the company right i was
hearing no from everyone gary like from
all the retailers i dreamed of carrying
our products that i used to shop in
right i would save my tip money like i
mentioned as a denny's waitress and buy
products at the department stores
and what what what year was this uh so
so we launched 2007 uh
like i quit my job 2007. i wrote the
business plan on my honeymoon flight to
south africa with my husband
not the most romantic way to kick off a
marriage and we both got back
uh quit our jobs dove all in i thought
gary maybe so many entrepreneurs
listening i thought
oh if i just pour everything i have and
actually create a product that works
like it's just gonna sell if it's that
good
it's just gonna sell uh and then i
didn't realize
it would be the heart i mean i've had a
lot of jobs in in my life but being an
entrepreneur is
by far well you especially also built
that brand different than building a
brand today where you can use shopify
and social media to build it you had to
get a yes
from sephora alta you know walmart
walgreens and you know macy whoever it
was
and that is difficult when you're
innovating the way you did
do you know that my whole life is now do
you know vaynermedia a lot of people
listening don't know this
most brands don't want to say yes to
vaynermedia we don't want to do a
commercial
and then go to sleep like we don't want
to take 12 weeks to do the perfect
commercial and then do print ads that
look like it or banner ads or digital
programmatic
my whole life building vaynermedia is no
everything i do is garyvee's easy i just
do it with the
audience but vaynermedia is exactly i
know what you're living through
because when you innovate and you're
doing something different and you don't
look the part
you didn't work at procter and gamble
for 13 years yeah
like what's this washington state thing
like they you know you know what it is
well and it's wild because i would go in
and start you know i would pitch the
product
and you know we were staying alive on
social media so we were getting
people were writing just blogs at that
point and we were selling like one to
three orders a day on our website and
people were spreading the word that was
the only way we barely stayed alive but
all the retailers exactly what you said
and by the way i've learned this like
when you're doing something that's
authentic or that is different
but even if it's just authentic to you
even in a crowded industry
by definition it's novel by definition
it's never been done before
and i really believe looking back now at
this journey and
and and every i believe that like even
even a lot of visionaries tatted
visionaries
i think they can't imagine anything
being successful unless subconsciously
they have
they have proof in the back but they've
already seen it it's already worked so
it's like
of course so many people are gonna say
no to your dream or doubt your dream if
they've never seen it done before and
we had three years of every single
beauty retailer saying no you're not the
right fit
uh it's not gonna work you're not right
for our customers and i kept and by the
way we talk about gut feeling i kept
having this gut feeling we're supposed
to go on qvc
because then i could actually like show
my bright red rosacea
and prove live that our product works
unlike the photoshopped ads on tv
and this is just something to share for
someone who might need to hear this
right now who's having a gut feeling but
they feel like they're wrong like i kept
having this feeling
and every time i would do a meeting with
qvc it would be a no
every phone call i'd finally get like i
got their head guy alan burke on the
phone
um he's like a legend he's responsible
for building this billion dollar
uh beauty empire on qvc and i finally
got him on a call and i thought for sure
it was going to be a yes
and because if he was taking his
precious time and it was about a minute
into the call and he said i just need to
let you know
we've reviewed your product with all the
buyers it's unanimous it's a no
you're not the right fit for qvc and of
course i like poured my heart out i'm
like oh
but i am the right fit and then i you
know we were down to under a thousand
dollars in our bank account at that
point so i remember like crying myself
to sleep and
long story short a year later when i
finally did get a yes
to go on qvc um i
took this big risk that that i was
advised not to by consultants
and i put real women of all shapes and
sizes and skin tones and skin challenges
and
i showed my own bare face and all the
things that had never been done before
we sold out at the 10 minute mark i was
crying on national television because
it's live qvc is live to 100 million
homes
you knew the truth and your heart would
win
not you know students telling you what
to do
yeah you know and and listen it was a
big
risk but i feel like i know this lesson
that like
i know this and now i've seen it play
out with thousands of entrepreneurs over
the years but you
i know that authenticity alone doesn't
guarantee success but
in authenticity guarantees failure
right i mean you are preaching
i'd rather die i'd rather die
than compromise my gut
yeah it just doesn't feel good enough
like if you're gonna lose
lose on your own sword yeah the worst
thing in the world to do is to lose
based on somebody else's advice i really
believe that yes
and you know what else to that don't
think don't even necessarily think
because you're losing right now
that you've lost and what i mean by that
go ahead i'm sorry
yeah oh no i was gonna say gary like
like so this is wild right so alan burke
the guy i just
mentioned after we finally got on to qvc
so he's the guy that said no i cried
myself to sleep yeah after um
we got onto qvc that one airing turned
into five that year
101 the next year and then i did over
250 live shows a year for eight years in
a row and
we built the largest beauty brand in
cubase history so it is right now at
this moment that you and i are talking
and when alan burke retired and by the
way he ended up being
becoming one of my greatest mentors
after we launched on qvc
um he's so brilliant to be honest and
after he retired we actually hired him
in a paid position on our advisory board
at cosmetics so the guy who rejected me
working for me i love that first of all
it's amazing i need a much
more interesting one at his retirement
dinner did he publicly say that you were
his biggest
miss and then later so here's the funny
thing
he would say that and he has said that
but here's what i know
i know that had he said yes sooner i
know that i didn't know what i didn't
know
had he said yes sooner we would have
failed because
do you not believe that a year earlier
you would have gone with your gut
i would have but at the time and maybe
this was just serendipitous grace
but at the time what i learned later was
uh we
you know the qvc's massive right like
the one airing i got i had to sell
6 000 units in 10 minutes to hit the
sales goal or not come back
um what i learned later was like had he
said yes any sooner
we were not operationally sophisticated
enough to handle an account that size on
the back end
so maybe that was just serendipity i see
you might have
you might have sold them up front but
logistically you were not prepared
right yeah and so i feel like that was
divine timing
in that case and you know and one other
one other thing to share too
just and by the way i knew in my gut we
were supposed to be on qvc but for three
years they said no
right and then we end up building the
biggest beauty brown and qvc's history
and i just want to share that because i
know there's people listening right now
that think like
oh i'm listening to my god i feel
strongly but i have no proof around me
that my business is succeeding or that
i'm not getting the traction i want or
i'm not getting but
can i throw something at you because
we're running out of time here as a
matter of fact
this is pissing me off i'm sorry i have
this hardcore meeting that i'm already
late for
um everyone this is what sucks about
actually being a businessman not a
content producer
when every time you like and i'm trying
to be better about not interrupting even
though i got excited here and i know i
interrupted many times
couple things one give everybody your
handles because i have a feeling a bunch
of new fans were just created so i want
to make sure they follow you
so they can continue journey to
vaynernation i'm telling you
this is very obvious to me you have to
buy this book which is coming out now or
you should pre
like i feel like we're going to air this
in a couple days which is probably a day
or two before the book comes out which i
think is the 23rd
so you should definitely go to amazon or
barnes nobles and pre-order it or order
it immediately
jim give the handles and give the name
of the book so everybody can find it
real quick
yeah yeah i'm gonna have one more
question okay thank you so jamie kern
lima and i'm at
jamie currently on instagram uh the book
is called believe it
and there's a ton of free gifts for this
week for your whole community on launch
uh for the launch of the book on
believeit.com so
giving a course away and a 95-page
action plan
that helps you implement all the lessons
from the book in your real life and
gary it's really a book for anyone who
just is struggling with self-doubt
and wants to know how to truly like
go from not believing themselves to
believing in themselves so it's called
believe it and everything's on believe
it dot com
do you do you believe that
had you failed as an elderly woman you
would have been thrilled
because at least you went for it yes
yes that's where i want to go with this
everyone this is the bow on this thing
or maybe the cherry on this very nice
cake i think what's
incredibly important in james message
is that part you may be sitting i love
what she's doing she communicates like i
do
she's trying to get into the psyche and
saying look i get it you're two years in
you're like i believe it i believe it
we don't know because many of you fall
into this camp
there are people who believe it and then
there are people who
genuinely are so not self-aware that
they're delusional
and they think they're gonna be
professional athletes when they can't
run or they can't jump
that happens and that's not fun for me
to say
but what i think is even if you aren't
destined
for this massive success it's still a
bigger
whether you're delusional or you believe
it i still think it's 75 at 95 at 103
you're going to be pumped that you went
for it because you won't have
regret jane yep i have goosebumps right
now that's everything you agree with
that
i agree that's everything all right
everybody please pick up the book as you
can tell my energy i'm excited about it
i'm sorry i had to
cut it a hair short um that is just the
reality of my life but i'm sure jamie
will be on the circuit so go google her
and find her
in other podcasts and things that nature
and we thank you and i'm stealing one
30 second moment for myself which i
rarely do so i'm going to do that bye
everybody jamie thank you so much
believeit.com go check it out
get the freebies with the book thank you
thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you